as you've written in uh referring to the
the previous Twitter CEO Elon said
Twitter needs a a fire breathing dragon
I think this is a good opportunity to
um maybe go through some of the
memorable moments of the Twitter Saga as
you've written about extensively in your
book like from the early days of
considering the acquisition to uh how it
went through to the details of uh like
you mentioned the engineering teams well
at the beginning of 2022
he was riding high but as we say he's a
drama addict he doesn't like the ghost
and you know Tesla sold a million
vehicles I think 33 boosters you know uh
uh Falcon nines have been shot up and
landed safely in the past few months
um
and he was the richest person on Earth
and times person of the year
and yet he said you know I'm still want
to put all my chips back on the table I
want to keep taking rest I don't want to
savor things he sold all of his houses
so he started secretly buying shares of
Twitter
the January February March becomes
public at a certain point he has to
declare it
and we were here in Austin
at gigafactory on the mezzanine and he
was trying to figure out well where do I
go from here
and at that time this early April they
were going to offer him a board seat he
was going to do a standstill agreement
and stop at 10 or something now remember
you know we were standing around it was
Luke nozick whom you know well Ken
hellery some of his friends on that
mezzanine here and all afternoon and
then late into the evening at dinner is
like should we do this and I didn't say
anything I'm just the Observer but
everybody else is saying excuse me why
do you want to own Twitter and Griffin
his son joined at dinner in May for some
reason was in town and like everybody
says no we don't use Twitter why would
you do that and may said well I use
Twitter and it's almost like okay the
demographics are people my age or Maize
Aid
um and so it looked like he wasn't going
to pursue it they offered him a board
seat
and
um
then he went off to Hawaii
to Larry Ellison's uh house which he
sometimes uses he was meeting a friend
Angela Bassett an actress and instead of
enjoying three days of vacation
he just became supercharged and started
firing off text messages including the
fire breathing dragon one I think you
know he used that phrase a few times
that powerog wasn't the person who was
going to take Twitter to a new level and
then by the time he gets to Vancouver
where Grimes meets him they stay up all
night playing Elden ring he was doing a
TED talk and then uh at 5 30 he finishes
playing the Eldon ring and sends out
that I've made an offer
uh even when he comes back people are
trying to intervene and say excuse me
why are you doing it
um and so it was a rocky period between
late April and October when the deal
closes and people ask me all the time
well did he want to get out of the deal
I said which Elon are you talking about
at what time of day yeah because
there'll be times in the morning when
he'd say oh the Delaware Court's going
to force me to do it it's horrible talk
to his lawyers you can win this case get
me out of it
he met here in Austin with three or four
investment bankers Blair Ephron it's
interview Bob Steele at perella Weinberg
and they offered him options do you want
to get out do you want to stay in do you
want to reduce the price
and I think his he was Mercurial there
were times he would text me or say to me
this is going to be great it's going to
be the accelerant
to do x.com the way we thought about 20
years ago
uh and so it's not until they finally
tell them at the beginning of October
right when Optimus the robot is being
unveiled in California actually
um the lawyer saying you're not going to
probably win this case but better go
through with the deal
and by then he's not only made his peace
with it he's kind of happy with it at
time
eventually the deal is going to close on
a I think a uh Friday morning I have it
in the book and we're there on Thursday
and he's wandering around looking at the
stay woke t-shirts and psychological
safety lingo they're all using and he
and his lawyers and bankers hatched a
plan to do a flash close
and the reason for that was if they
closed the deal after the markets had
closed for the day
and he could send a letter to parag and
two others firing them quote for cause
and this will be something the courts
will have to figure out
uh then he could save 200 million or so
and it was both the money but for him a
matter I won't say a principle but of
hey they misled me about the numbers I
got forced into doing it so I'm gonna
I'm gonna try this Jiu Jitsu maneuver
and be able to get the money out of them
then when he takes over it's kind of a
wild scene
um
him trying to decide in three different
rounds how to get the staff down to 15
percent of what it was him deciding on
Christmas Eve after he'd been at a
meeting where they told him we can't get
rid of that Sacramento server Farm
because it's needed for redundancy he
says no it's not and he's flying here to
Austin and young James says why don't we
just do it ourselves he turns the plane
around they land in Sacramento and he
pulls him out himself so it was a manic
period we should also say that
underneath of that there was a
a running desire to or consideration to
perhaps start a new uh companies to
build the social media company from
scratch well Kimball wanted to do that
and Kimball here at a wonderful
restaurant in Austin of launches like
hey why are you buying Twitter let's
start one from scratch and do it on the
blockchain yeah now it took them a while
and you can argue it one way or the
other
to come to the conclusion that the
blockchain was not fast enough in
responsive time enough to be able to
handle a billion tweets you know in a
day or so
he gets mad when they keep trying to get
him to talk to Sam bankman freed who's
trying to say I'll invest but we have to
do it on the blockchain Kimball is still
in favor of starting a new one and doing
it on uh blockchain based
in retrospect
I think starting a new Media Company
would have been better he wouldn't have
had the baggage or the Legacy that he's
breaking now in Breaking the way Twitter
had been but it's hard to have millions
and millions hundreds of millions of
true
true users not just trolls and start
from scratch as others have found as
Mastodon and blue sky and threads and
not any threads even had a base so it
would have been hard